the next award is very unusual it's for
Best Supporting Actor it's unusual
because this year there isn't an
Englishman on the list the presentation
was made by a young star who when she
was even younger won the Oscar herself
for stunning performance in the miracle
worker miss Patty Duke
congratulations patty - tell me you're
great in Valley of the dolls oh I
wouldn't know my mother wouldn't let me
see it what a coincidence
oh really your mother wouldn't let you
see it either my mother doesn't mind
it's my doctor
for Best Performance by an actor in a
supporting role
we of the Academy have nominated John
Cassavetes for his role in the Dirty
Dozen gene Hackman in Bonnie and Clyde
Cecil Calloway in guess who's coming to
dinner
Michael J Pollard in Bonnie and Clyde
and George Kennedy in Cool Hand Luke
the winner is George Kennedy in
well I could bust I have to thank Stuart
Rosenberg for giving me the opportunity
to even be here and I must simply thank
the Academy for the greatest moment of
my life
you